you know what's crazy is that on the
west coast we have blast who's kind of
like the other guy doing that right
have you guys connected or you broke me
out in brooklyn that's crazy so you and
so are you have you blast is another guy
who does everything himself he records
himself makes the beat does all that you
guys work on any music
some [ __ ] just just knows that that'd be
a good decade just know so you and blast
got music together you understand what
it's just a lot going on so that means
yes nice who made the beat though if
both of you guys make the the beat
like you guys both make beats so who
made them
who made the beat he's the ghost did you
handle the beat or did the blast handle
the beat
it's a lot going on i can't wait until
everybody sees what's in store for this
decade you understand man i like how you
talking in decades yeah absolutely
because it's not because i'm not here
for it for this record i'm right here
for this year
right i'm taking it a decade at a time